so for someone not from the UK there's
no more quintessential
British TV series than Doctor Who what
is it about Doctor Who that translates
you think globally escapism different
world seeing new things here new aliens
creatures and stuff and everyone's
supposed to escape sometimes and I think
because it's been doing that for such a
long period of time over 50 years it
just you know translate over the time
and I think he would want to escape
sometimes and just have fun and see
different things yeah I think their
companions are very ordinary people in
extraordinary circumstances so I think
that that can cross globally like no
matter where you are you can actually
relate to companions and the situations
and the emotions that they go through I
think that just translates as being the
brand-new cast of this season I think
the fact that the show has worked for so
long is because this new injection of
energy is put into it and so the POV
shifts all the time which keeps it
interesting keeps it current and keeps
it relevant to to the world we're
entering the worlds that were from and
and also with the right in we it can
encompass the things that have gone
before and the things that we
potentially not predicting but are using
what's happening now to kind of reflect
in the stories that were telling yeah
for Doctor Who fans one of the biggest
things about the shows actually
unveiling of the new doctor every series
and Jody you being the first female
doctor is a huge step breaking the glass
ceiling so to speak what has the fan
reaction been for you personally
well I am I'm not on social media so I
only get told and everyone only told me
the nice bits so I think I think it was
a very nice I'm sure there was a few
hashtag not my doctor but that happens
every that happens every time I think
just you know the thing about Doctor Who
and the reason why who viens has such a
wonderful fan base and so supportive and
inclusive is because they used to change
and they celebrate the change and they
and they crave it often and as well and
so for me to you know be placing these
xiii shoes on its it's exciting but it's
different but it's not that different
it's not it's not breaking the form of
the show in any way one of the big
topics of conversation when it comes to
series and movies here in north america
is inclusion of diversity like people
have color different types of people in
these areas and in these movies but it
seems like in the UK you guys have been
doing that forever
every show i see has all sorts of
different types of people i would
disagree with that i think i I don't and
I I don't think it's hard to say that
but I think it it's the UK's television
landscape isn't as progressive that's
the US and I feel like I don't know for
me personally it has a black person I
feel like every time I see people have
mark on the hall
anything to see on TVs or movies is like
an event because you only get that one
or two a year so for me to watch
something yeah oh look it's my friend
he's on TV and I think that now that
dialogues kind of changing them or we
are talking about it more and we are
acting upon it more and I just think
it's time you know which reflects in the
time as current you know ethnic people
have been around forever yeah you know
so this is good that we just reflect on
modern-day society and put it on screen
so the younger generation can see that
and be inspired and see people like them
and relate more to themselves you know
for Doctor Who fans also watching a new
series there are certain elements that
they expect right the the TARDIS the
sonic screwdriver certain types of
monsters that they hope to see come back
how do you balance bringing new elements
in with sort of the elements that people
want to see I think this year with a new
doctor and actually what we've talked
about doing for the show you want there
to be no barrier to entry for for new
viewers new audiences and for us the
task this year is where does the show go
next where's it go next with this doctor
this gang of friends so we got loads of
new monsters loads of new characters
those new villains loads of new settings
we've got a new sonic screwdriver who
knows about the TARDIS that exploded at
the end of the Christmas special I don't
know if we're ever see that again um but
um really it's about the new and about
the going forward but also there's
little nuggets and kisses for the fans
in there as well too
one thing that's really cool is you know
special guest appearances we already
know that Alan [ __ ] is gonna be doing
some of us might know that especially
tell us about any other special guests
can you drop any hints or surprises
absolutely not
when you find out who they are you're
gonna be really excited every episode
this year has some really great guest
stars in and and some familiar faces all
right fantastic head lift about that one
I like